[Music]
hello welcome to episode 36 of GameSpot
after stark GameSpot's official video
game podcast I'm your host Jake Decker
in this week joining me is Lucy James
hello
tomorrow Hussein hi and John Luke psyche
hello so this week the big topic we have
is Final Fantasy 7 two more reviewed it
John Luke has played quite a bit we are
gonna get to that before we do that
we're gonna run through what we've been
playing there's a couple news stories we
want to hit a big one that we missed
last week both of them are regarding
Sony it's the controller and Last of Us
2 getting delayed as well as Ironman and
then we'll move on to listener questions
but without further ado shall we start
with you Lucy do you want to talk about
what you've been doing yeah so I have
been I made a decision to myself then I
was gonna get the Platinum in persona 5
royal so that's what yeah actually it is
way more attainable in royal than it is
in the main name which I didn't go for I
think I got like half the trophies in
the main game but in Royal I was like
well I'm gonna replay it anyway I might
as well get a the Platinum or something
you don't have to finish the compendium
the only thing you have to do is max all
your confidence and your social skills
which is super easy to do because you
have so much more free time yeah it's
like I'm getting to the point now where
I just finished the first palace I have
all of these like the new story beats
like I'm meeting the new what the
counselor like didn't one of the new
confidence Meru key and man I just
forgot how good that game was I never
forgot how good persona 5 was but I'm
glad that I had a break of a couple of
years and now I can just really oh god I
spent about seven hours playing it on
Sunday like I have a spreadsheet I'm
trying to use there's an old guide that
tells you day by day what you should be
doing in persona 5 it's changed because
things happen in different days in royal
but you can kind of use it as a loose
framework I'm having a very exciting
time with
because I I told myself I wasn't gonna
replay it I didn't think I had any
interest in replaying it but then I saw
Michaels review and I've seen like I've
seen some of the new characters and I
got a lot of time on my hands it's kind
of like maybe I should do it but I'm
gonna wait I'm at least gonna wait to
get through Final Fantasy 7 because I
haven't touched that yet
and I and I definitely want to play
through that yeah that's the thing it's
like in the way that everyone was
talking about the game pre-release all
the new story stuff seems to come quite
late in but the new combat stuff and the
palace layout changes from the get-go
so for me after having a couple years
break and going into royal I was like
this feels like a whole new game like I
remember bits of it but I don't remember
a lot of things that I'm kind of
experiencing now and royal and yeah
Michaels review when I read it and I saw
the amazing video edit the gesture I was
like yeah okay yeah I'm back I'm like a
full John wick I'm thinking I'm back I
mean that's me yeah I've been playing as
well and the rhythm of the game is so
comfortable to get into it's like such a
comforting game despite the fact that
it's subject matter is quite heavy at
times but yeah just the day-to-day
rhythm of that stuff it like if it's got
a lot of the animal crossing style thing
that we're all enjoying now you can jump
in and do these certain things and then
tackle a big chunk of the game and then
come back and do that again layer it's
just really comforting to play well
that's kinda what I was thinking if I
return to it I don't think I would binge
it I mean I say that now maybe I would
end up binging it but I I think what I
would do is I would just do a couple
days every day and kind of just slowly
trek through the games already know
largely what's gonna happen I know the
different beats I don't remember a lot
of it but I think I think if I came back
to it that would be the play because I
can't see myself just sitting down it's
been 12 hours playing with all these
other games coming out but I could
definitely see myself just taking it a
couple days at a time yeah I think it's
one of those games that's really built
for that
hmm God the soundtrack man it's so good
like the new song and I know Michael had
some hot takes that he thought the new
ambush battle song was better than last
surprise but man I think he might be
right yeah I got a I got a sound bar
recently and we got the exact same one
yeah we've got the exact same sound bar
and the same TV we've got the same tech
self here in the same room just like
what what some part is that the vizio I
have the exact same sound what Brandon
size TV do you have Samsung also Samsung
yes Wow sale at Best Buy last year no I
got mine a couple years ago but I think
it's like a very similar model you
probably have like the slightly newer
version yeah but like Harry go well
together
hearing that soundtrack come through a
nice sound system there's nothing like
it it's so good like I've been I usually
play with headphones because I don't
want to disturb anyone around me but
with that game I've been putting it out
crank it yeah how can you disturb people
with that music I mean I'm playing at
like 4:00 a.m. in the morning I haven't
started the game yet but I did download
the like dynamic menu theme that comes
with the game and it just blasts the new
intro theme on loop and so I just leave
that on and like it's wonderful just
gets me in the jam I'm ready for it
nice well I figured since you two have
been playing well actually two more you
played a bit of Valerie didn't you
before we get into I've been playing in
Final Fantasy do you want to talk about
Valerie in a little bit because that
seems exciting yeah so Valerie is the
latest team-based tactical shooter from
Riot Games which people know for League
of Legends and more recently team fight
tactics and it's weird to say this but
it is exactly what it looks like if
you're looking at a video or an image
it's overwatch crossed with Counter
Strike and it is very much feeling like
Counter Strike to the point where I
texted hime yes and I was like
display some veteran might start playing
counter-strike again it's very very
familiar it's got the same kind of
feeling to it in terms of it's very
quick time to death in that not not in
this Call of Duty way where you run
headfirst into battle and hope for the
best more that like a single shot is
enough to take you out if it's a
well-placed headshot and then you're
unlike it's very classic in the way it
feels
unlike siege you don't have much to do
beyond just watching your teammates you
can't jump into the cams and see where
enemies are and flag them and highlight
them and communicate with your team
you're just pretty much sitting out and
hoping that the rest of the team does
does their job and the game-mode I
played was the classic I don't know what
the veteran term for it is but it was
applying the bomb and then defending it
until it goes off the big twist is that
you have overwatch like a Billy's I love
them okie-dokie
it's it's alarming how similar they are
so there's a character who will fire a
sonar arrow that will tell you where
enemies are in the local area it's an
English is a cockney English lad but
it's that's that's Deva right from I
[Laughter]
it's Hanzo thank you
and then there's a character the
character I played was fight these balls
of energy that could be used you could
use one to heal your enemies or self
heal you could use the other one as an
AoE that slows people down in the same
way that Moira's ball might be as it
would connect might do as it would
connect with an enemy the other
characters are like you can put there's
another character who can put walls up
in the same way made us it's a lot of
familiar abilities but the thing to know
is like those aren't you need to avoid
those are unique then they're like
common among many many MOBAs RPGs I
think within the framework of a
first-person shooter it feels more black
it belongs to overwash and in that
regard it is true it is aping a lot of
what overwatch does but I think what
really sets it apart from overwatch is
the counter-strike found
it's building on counter-strike unless
you're super familiar with it you don't
really know is it but like it's all
about the economy at the start of each
round is a buying phase in the same way
there is in modern MOBAs where you stock
up on guns armor and and in this you
don't have abilities on a cool-down you
have to buy them so that so if you want
to use that like AoE that slows people
down you have to spend money on that and
you can hold maybe like two of them and
if you want to spend money on the
healing charge for example you have to
do you can only hold one of them so you
have to be smart about how you use your
money and how you use what you're buying
at any time and the ultimate is always
like charging all the time and everyone
has their own all the character I use
use the resurrection so you can which is
very weird for a counter-strike game
where you can bring a character back
into the mix but the Bioeconomy is super
important it's unclear how good it is
right now is it's a part of Counter
Strike that takes a lot of refinement
and still is being refined because you
know something being slightly too
expensive can can really upset the
balance of the economy but it's got some
interesting things like it's been a
while since I've played counter-strike
I've played a lot of caltrak in my time
but less so of like global orphans or
global Offensive norm carnivores code
but you can do things like yeah you can
sell sell items now and like you can do
smart things like tell your enemy T&E
tell your teammates that you've got
extra money and in which case they can
buy stuff and counter-strike you just
buy and chuck it on the ground but you
can like request stuff as one be like
hey I want this gun can someone buy it
for me and beyond that it's a very slow
methodical tactical first-person shooter
it's a lot of like walking slowly to
make sure they can't hear your footsteps
checking your corners and like crouching
you don't want to be moving when you
fire because this way and like the
reticle will blossom out and you will
struggle to control unless your shroud
and you can very carefully control the
spray pattern but it very much feels
like counter-strike and it's doing it
for me because of that the the one thing
I'd say about it right now it feels very
unpolished in the way visually it looks
it feels like it's a pretender to the
overwatch style I don't want to describe
I don't want to mari as that but like
it doesn't it has the same kind of
cartoony visual style and it's like the
but the world isn't as interesting it's
like this weird cartoon version of de
dust2 from counter-strike and the
characters themselves or don't feel
super fleshed out and the even the
visual style is cartoony and associated
but doesn't have the gloss of an
overwatch style thing it's it's less
pixar and more DreamWorks if you get
what I'm saying but that's that's kind
of how I feel about nevertheless like
the gameplay as it stands feels like
solid it feels fun I'm excited to go
back to player I know that I was trying
to hire my body and higham was like our
thing I'm hooked I know Dave Jue in the
UK is playing it and he's enjoying it as
well it's got some issues right now with
people just disconnecting and not
sticking it through and I think the
modern mentality of multiplayer games is
somewhat clashing with the classical
approach of counter-strike
you can't just get killed and bounce
like and be like I'm done with this you
ruin a game like that so yeah it's
promising a question I have is how did
you think it balances these abilities
super well with that sort of hardcore
QuickTime to death counter-strike side
because I I for one was curious when
they announced it because I mean siege
kind of struggles with this too but a
lot of times it's like okay I have this
ability that could do this but wouldn't
it make more sense for me to just shoot
this character in the head since they're
gonna die so soon like I feel like
overwatch since there's longer time the
kills like it makes more sense to invest
in using some of these abilities as
opposed to just going straight in for
the kill yeah I think the difference is
a lot of the abilities that I've seen
thus far aren't like directly attacking
an enemy if you get one saying it's not
like you're you're firing a beam at
another player or shooting a Deever bomb
into an area it's more like making life
slightly difficult for them like the AoE
thing is designed to slow them down so
if you put that like around the bomb for
example they'll struggle to rush the
bomb and defuse it or if you're doing
like healing it's the the ball that you
fire at your enemies can not enemy say
your teammates for example it's very
much support it that you can't also use
it to attack another enemy and the walls
for example are probably
like they're not all that difficult
they're not upsetting the balance right
now they like area-denial but they can
shoot in through it eventually and get
through it there's one character that
does like puts up this almost like crazy
geyser of energy and all that it does is
like anyone quite like passes through on
your team or heal them
so it feels more like how can you slow
people down and create an advance for
yourself without directly attacking the
enemy okay it seems like there's a
separation between what you do you know
how you win through attacking which is
still skill based and the abilities
which are designed to try and give you a
slight edge to it that makes sense yeah
I'm excited to try it I just I I didn't
get in on the close of a day I don't
have a right account I've never had a
right account and like part of me is
just like I just built a new PC I don't
want to like toss in a ton of like game
launchers like I already downloaded the
Rockstar launch or steam you playing all
this stuff that's like I don't want to
it's so stupid it's so stupid but I'd
still launcher in here I'm in the same
thing I've got this new gaming laptop
and I'm trying not to put anything on
there so it's I would I'd download I
create a write account for this and like
I keep thinking and if you uninstall
this as soon as this is done
yeah also the right account the valoran
icon it looks like an Adobe product so I
keep trying to find where is I'm like
where is that right I stay as far away
it just looks like Adobe velour and oh
ever well well anyway yeah I'm excited
to play John Luke are you planning on
checking it out at all maybe i've i like
counter-strike but i've never been very
good at it but that was kind of i've
been getting better at shooters now like
you know ever since I started playing
siege more often I feel like that games
ya got me better at shooters so I'd like
to give it a try I definitely want to I
think I need to play with people though
like every time I've tried to play
counter-strike and I'm playing by myself
yeah I don't have I don't have a good
time I need to have a squad so if people
like Michael are like really into it
maybe I'll I'll find a way to get my
hands on it it's super important to play
with like other people like I paid with
a team yesterday and I I mean I was the
I'm part of it because I wasn't on Mike
I was like I'm just gonna play a few
games I don't want any want to talk to
people but I was clearly a a kind of
stumbling block for communication there
was only like one or two people they had
this amazing moment though where I was
on the menu screen picking a character
but I like click the character and I was
like oh okay cool I'll read what this
character can do so I'm reading it but I
hadn't like locked in the character and
the time was ticking and then over the
Mike someone whispered make a character
and I was like and I pressed it and
anyway that dude was like whispering the
entire times like the secret game I was
like fair enough but yeah it's super
important because yeah you need to make
call out sound like you need to be like
I need we need to rush a rush B you know
see you know that kind of stuff so yeah
if you if you guys do play it let me
know I'm happy to hop on and work with
play with you guys yeah I definitely
will at some point it so the close
debate is going on now right yeah sure
like it'll probably be over by the time
this is I heard it was supposed to be
sure yeah they said it's gonna be
relatively short but they haven't
actually added a ending point yet I feel
like you might be one of them ones where
it's like all right it's gonna we've
extended it we've extended it again
we've extended it a third time more
people can come that's what they do
watch transition into an open beta yeah
I think that would be the smart thing to
do it was having some hiccups when it
first launched but it seems to be in a
little more stable place now speaking of
riot I have been getting teamfight
tactics
ads go on everything and they're the
most annoying bad they're like they're
like they sound like they're recorded on
like really crappy microphones and
they're like it's like these little
stick figures like hey have you heard a
teamfight tactics and I'm like yes I
have
you don't show this to me anymore
control-alt-delete comics sorry cuz I
just get the anti-jew lads yes oh my god
I don't do like I hate those adverts
I think those ads are just like a a riot
thing because I remember years ago I
used to get like League of Legends ads
that looks like they were made by
youtubers like there were like YouTube
videos and be like animated yeah they
looked like control to leave videos or
something but they were psych hey go
play League of Legends and it was like
the jewel ones before we go move on from
here like they have some intense boomer
energy like oh my god it's like it's
like hey kids get rid of your jewel and
it's like a lady or or dude or a
teenager putting the jewel into a cup
and then pouring orange juice over it
and then or like doing the mentos thing
with a jewel and I'm like what's this
all about and it always ends with this
sound thing which is a lady going OK by
E and it's so frustrating you're so
annoying and like I'm like I vape I'm
just like I'm gonna buy more jewels if
you keep doing this anyway I'll go over
what I've been playing quickly so you
can move on the Final Fantasy 7 but I
finished half-life Alex like I said I
built a PC and boy this half-life Alex
run much better on my quest now that
I've worked out a lot of the issues with
my PC and as someone who I mean I
started playing the half-life games a
couple weeks ago I've kind of tracked my
progress with this podcast over the past
couple weeks and having finished
half-life Alex don't worry Jon that
can't even finish don't spoil anything
but I was incredibly impressed with the
ending I'm super excited for the future
of that series and like I want to go
back and replay Alex I want to replay
some of the older half-life games as
well again even though I just played him
a couple weeks ago but like I man like
even as someone who jumped on board
pretty late here you could tell like I
was nervous that they'd mess up the
ending somehow and they found a way and
they hit it out of the park and it like
I don't know this series is in such an
interesting place right now and part of
me is like trying not to get too excited
for the future because you know it is
valve but that ending there is there
clear that like they are really thinking
about the future of this series and
they've got some big things planned oh
man that's so exciting
yeah like cuz yeah Michael just keeps
like the other day he was even like oh
you finished it yeah I want he just he's
like begging to talk to me about the
ending and I need to finish it I think
I'm gonna do it this weekend because
ever you really should about it it's
just like holy [ __ ] it's incredible and
like I need to know I need to know I've
waited with 13 years it went from like a
really great VR game at the beginning
which III thought I thought the
introduction was excellent in that game
and how it showed you all the mechanics
of VR without really showing you the
mechanics of VR like this is how you do
it did it very smartly yeah there were
certain instances like the gravity
gloves for example they like had very
direct tutorials telling you how to do
it but I really liked the intro and as I
was playing through it I was like okay
I'm pretty into this but that second
half when things start to fall into
place I was like I told myself like
alright I'm just gonna play an hour
tonight and get through it later this
week but I sat down and up playing four
hours of it just in one sitting because
I was so engrossed in what was going on
but yeah for me it's definitely
definitely gonna be at least somewhere
in my top ten this year I bet because I
was incredibly impressed
damn dude do you know if you find golden
frame as possible in that I was watching
that the other day oh my god Dave sent
it to me I was talking with Dave on
Tuesday about something and he sent it
to me and I just I just started like I
watched there I watched the live stream
of it when it was first showing and I
was like this is while this is the best
thing I've seen it was like three
there's a serious quarter half life VR
but the AI is self-aware
and it's just a dude playing as Gordon
Freeman but the characters around him ha
clearly being played by other people the
voice by his friends I think yeah but
it's just so funny and I saw it and it's
like the first person you meet is a God
who just demands to see Gordon Freeman's
Passport
but it's like what are you talking about
I'm in a cheesy suit I'm literally
supposed to be here they're rushing me
in person yeah I'm the only one with the
suit but it's so I remember watching and
then I watched like episode three came
out and I was like aw crap I need to
catch up on this and I watched it it was
so far I sent it to I think I sent it to
Jake I said it's Kelly I sent it to
Danny or Dwyer who posted it on Twitter
saying it's Dave I said it I said it to
everyone I knew that has like the
remotest interest in it and it's just
like II the [ __ ] I I think it's the best
thing I watched on YouTube in the best
most original idea for let's play yeah I
I want to know like how they made it
like this vote yes it's a mod he guy
made it I don't I think it was on reddit
someone found the mod and we're posting
about it um see yeah that's how they're
doing it but honestly just the hello
Gordon hello guy that guy in particular
yeah she's so he's I thought he was a
robot because he like talks he sounds
just like one of the scientists they
sound you know slightly the same man and
and he there is a moment where he was
like talking and then got grabbed and it
sounded almost like he it sounds like in
the game when like one line gets
interrupted by another line and it was
like is that a robot is that a real
person I was like I couldn't figure it
out and there's something like dr.
Coomer is amazing
there's a guy sir this is some lines
where like this wonder which house I was
rewatching anode episode and one of the
scientists just shots you're a filthy
little sewer boy aren't you Gordon and I
just I just like I just died I was like
I can't you and this this is too much
it's just like that is the most funny
thing I've seen in so long
and it would sit what's it called like
was a title half-life via but the AI is
self-aware yeah yeah the acting is like
so good like the things the guy who
plays Gordon does such a great job like
yeah trying to play it straight and like
pretending like he's really Gordon
Freeman in this situation and this is
how this episode Gordon Freeman's past
for me yeah this that the God when he
does the calming technique the black
makes a calming noise except the people
just goes like a blue light fires out
they would they work on that that that
gag becomes amazing when you get like
deeper into it it's such a good show
such a good you gotta watch more of it I
only watched the episode you send me is
so good anyway other than half-life Alex
I haven't finished our e3 but I'm about
our e3 remake I'm about a couple hours
in I'm enjoying it well enough
you know it's it's been fun I I don't I
can already tell I'm not gonna go back
and replay it multiple times like I did
with Resident Evil 2 it just it doesn't
have that same atmosphere I don't know
it's just not quite doing it for me I
don't even really mind all the set
pieces in this game like I think they're
fine but I think it's the moments in
between that are still I think all
Thunder I mentioned this in his review
but it all just feels so rushed like it
just feels like I'm going from one place
to the next before I can even really
soak in where I am like get an
understanding of where different things
are and it just I don't know like I know
some people some people kind of prefer
this more or prefer this more than
Resident Evil 2 just because you're not
backtracking a lot but I don't know I
kind of liked learning an area like
intimately and figuring out where all
the secrets were and where the doors
were and whatnot and like coming up with
routes that I could use to get to
certain places while trying to avoid mr.
X while this is just kind of like
alright I'm in an area I'm gonna loot as
much as I can until the next until the
next set piece happens and then I'm
gonna shoot the Nemesis a bunch in this
arena and then move on to the next part
yeah I think it's like what you said the
the set pieces are
but at the end of the day like what I
remember the most about my playthrough
resin evil - was like those like those
random moments that happen that are like
unscripted with like mr. X or like a
zombie like just just those like like
player like water cooler moments and I
don't feel like any of that happened for
me in Resident well 3 it was like yeah
that scripted moment was cool but like I
I didn't come away like having any
particular fond like moments the way I
did with I would - yes sure that's one
of my favorite Resident Evil so I was
really excited to play and then I heard
the stuff I read alesandro's review and
I was like that's a crying shame it
seems like they didn't put in as much
effort or didn't have as much ambition
for as they did with the re - remake
we're just resources resources as well
I mean imagined that they were developed
in parallel but I don't know yeah I like
overall like it's not it's not a bad
game by any stretch like I've been
having fun with it and I think it's it's
it's polished it's it's still it still
resonates so it's it's fun seeing like
Jill in those situations and whatnot and
I I don't regret because I didn't get a
code for it so I bought it and I don't
regret buying it but at the same time
it's like yeah this is yeah I'm not
gonna be playing this nearly as much as
I did Ari - and it definitely won't have
the same effect that re to remake had on
me and my job someone who whose first
Resident Evil game was Resident Evil 4
so I didn't play the original Resident
Evil 2 I didn't play the original
resident evil 3 this is just someone who
is kind of catching up through these
remakes and yeah so far I think Ari 2 is
definitely my favorite of the remake so
far oh yeah I would say like - is sort
of like that one end of the spectrum of
like that open-ended survival horror and
4 is like the peak like linear but like
really tight action this kind of feels
like it's somewhere in between where
it's just like yeah it's not as like
open-ended is already - but it's action
set-pieces aren't as tight as 4 so like
it just kind of sits in the middle
and it's fine but it like it doesn't it
never hit any of the highs of that
series for me it does not hit different
now it does not know you know it does it
different though hello Gordon so before
we get into Final Fantasy seven sorry to
do this but I kind of want to run
through the other topics quickly just so
we can get them out of the way all right
from and safe Final Fantasy seven the
first one is one that we missed last
week that I we put in the title because
we wanted people to know that you know
we recorded it before this yeah but but
this is a big one something that I'm
very bummed about makes a lot of sense
but the last was part two has been
delayed and what is more disappointing
is that there's no set release date I
think Sony has even been refunding
digital purchases so it sounds like this
delay could be for a very long time
I am so bummed I was so excited for this
game as many other people like I totally
get it like I don't want to put I don't
want any of these people at risk I don't
want them to go into - to their job to
work on a video like yeah no they should
work from home and like it's also such a
weird game to release right now yeah but
I'm so bummed
it's killing me I think that was I mean
maybe I'm wrong but from what like Neil
druckmann was saying the game is
basically done I think the issue is more
that Sony didn't want to release it
because like just the climate of
releasing that game wouldn't yeah it's
not just you know like totally it's not
just yeah yeah that's what I'm everyone
is market Iron Man is well got a delay -
just weeks before do you think this is
going to affect like ghosts of Tsushima
like how it was like they they had this
like very clear like Last of Us goes to
the Tsushima and that's setting up the
PS 5 like I kind of you know I kind of
feel like they were able to do the Last
of Us delay because they have ghosts of
Tsushima and I feel like they were like
we can put our Tsushima that's
like ready to roll and last of us is the
climate is not there right now the
marking and the the the distribution
that they want to put behind that is no
disrespect to Gaza Tsushima I'm
incredibly excited for it and it's very
much looks like my jam but like the
scale difference between distribution
marketing between loss of us two and
Tsushima is vast totally yeah like they
probably spent I mean it's not a dog
right Sony probably invested so much
money into this game that they want this
launch to be like flawless you know they
want as many people to buy this game as
possible
and if they released it now like Lucy
was just saying they cut off a big
portion of those those like retail sales
I I said is - is also kind of me hoping
that Tsushima doesn't get delayed
because I desperately won't play that
game I want to play when it comes to
retail what the split is between Amazon
and brick-and-mortar stores like game
and Game Stop now nowadays because I
wonder if this is to do with Amazon
putting saying you know non-essential
items are gonna get delayed obviously
the launch of Final Fantasy 7 has been
bizarre to watch play out like just
stores in Australia and the UK and
Europe just going screw it we're gonna
be closing soon come in and buy it so I
understand the Sony wouldn't want that
situation with a title like last was
part 2 especially because people will
hey there's already gameplay that's
leaked online so do not look for that
yeah there's also safety concerns right
because like I don't know how much
thought there's on their side put into
this I assume it's a lot but like a game
like loss of us which is hotly
anticipated probably one of the biggest
game releases for that console
definitely of this year like people are
desperate enough to play it to do stupid
things to get it like if they put it out
as normal there's probably a good chance
that people have been like I'm going to
store I need lost of us and like a
certain point they're probably
considering how much of a responsibility
do they have to ensure that they're not
creating
Constance's where people are putting
themselves at risk we saw what gamestop
did where they were like we're still
gonna release these games you can come
and buy them and the backlash to that
was loud and very very deserved and I
bet you they're probably thinking we
don't need to be in that situation we
can't become part of the problem when
everyone else is saying stay home you
know you know isolate don't do these XYZ
things and those happen to be like
essential things like traveling for work
putting out a video game that people are
gonna want to go to the store and break
those rules for is probably a concern
potentially even a legal wrist if they
if they did it it could result in some
sort of like backlash from governments
and you know it's just generally a bad
idea so it's understandable as bombed as
we are yeah well I mean I it still is
crazy to think that they have no set
release date either like because you
can't just be like all right things are
cleared up so we're gonna really slice
this in two weeks like you have a whole
like marketing train that needs to be
started up again and get going like you
can't just like okay looks like we're
good Naughty Dog time to release Last of
Us now can do it in a couple days like I
imagine like this delay I don't know I I
hope we get it I bet it'll be fall yeah
I think yeah people are banding around
end of August but I don't know what
that's based on maybe it's just wishful
thinking I mean technically it could be
a ps5 launch title like if it goes far
enough yeah if it goes far enough and
like that is a given the circumstances
that is a decent case scenario like it
comes out they push it all the way to PS
5 launch they're still confident in
putting this in their timeframe for ps5
even though it's not specific yet but
having a loss of us game available and
playable there they could spend the time
from now until then optimizing it for PS
5 and having that available launch is a
decent concession on their part and for
people like assets they say it's a
glass-half-full way to think about it
yeah I mean I I could definitely see
that I could see it because it I mean
from what we've heard so far it sound
like both Sony and Microsoft are still
on track to get their console out this
this fall yeah you can play it on their
brand-new controller
oh yes moving right along here which
they tweeted yesterday out of the blue
and it's so this is preempted this
before time exposes me I wasn't gonna
say anything I'm not that kind of person
you said you recorded it and you're
gonna post on life yeah I said that for
pants you know yeah so me meet him
Simon cardi front of the show and
blessing from kind of funny
we're playing overwatch yesterday it's
ham kind of goes Oh Sony's just
announced a new controller and we
thought it on sorry its blessing not a
friend of the show blessing it's it's
because every time I mentioned cardi I
always say I always show Simon the show
yeah possibly blessing in front of the
show
we're playing overwatch and we thought
he just meant like they announced a new
color of Jill shock fall and the way
that the conversation was going is that
like it was really fragmented
and then you said it's called duel sense
which I said sound well we all just said
like this is completely fake this is not
real they were they were actively
mocking me this is this is when you can
tell time to lying when you makes up
things like a do all sense
oh yeah it's a jewel sense like it
sounded like you were reaching to make
that anyway and then don't trust the
former head of news for GameSpot have a
favor for your breaking news according
to your Twitter feed it still says head
of news which yeah also like jewel cents
read that name I get that they're
pushing the haptic feedback but it
sounds a little bit like a sec story
because that's why I thought it was a
joke because it sounds like we should
have one of those
we are one of those that like destroy
your jewel videos for a dual sense okay
bye anyway controller looks cool I mean
I don't know I feel like you can't
really
judgey controller until you hold it and
play a game with it but I was surprised
that it was white I mean yeah I'm
actually kind of happy it's why I I go
back on it I know some people were like
oh it's gonna get fingerprints and
whites
you know like blacks a lot better for
that and but like honestly I like fun
colors on things I hate that all of my
consoles are just these like black
bricks
I like the opposite I love it
what is the want a white wood quote
where it's like you can have your car
any color you want as long as it's black
that's me nah man I want that orange
Gamecube I want fun colors so I'm
excited but the PS 5 might be white it
might look different no ice yeah I got
the I got the gray the black and grey
switch joy cons cuz and then I got the
grey switch light because I was like all
these colors look fun but I don't want
any of them see I have yeah I have all
black but my switch icons are yellow and
it drives me mad and I hate it and I can
see and like my controllers are blue and
red and because I have the Monster
Hunter ps4 Pro which is I'm not gonna
lie I love Monster Hunter it's one of
the most hideous ps4 pros controllers
the controller is god-awful and I'm like
what is this it's gross but the actual
ps4 looks super slick but the color
mismatch I like it to be like like you
are loose you're like blend it in I
don't want to see the technology but I
mean I mean you can't see because it's
hidden behind my plant but I have the
Xbox 1x Taco Bell Edition so because I
needed a 1x I had a one but I wanted
next and it's like a weed black gray
white sort of gradient thing and even
that puts me off so I've hidden it
behind my mom's I love color more colors
I'll take a ball that's how I call my
room with my lights
I mean if everything else is sleek and
you know the thing the thing to remember
too right
is that like the control you're gonna
get on a launch like ps5 you're gonna
get rid of in a couple years probably
Robert is gonna wear off in like a month
yeah I mean hopefully they fix that but
to do is I want them to release a
version with I mean the the face buttons
don't have the colors attach them like
the Browse green triangle and whatever
so I was like I'd like it I'd like them
to do a vision where it looks like that
the thing that I think actually I mean
pretty upset that they they're
continuing off this trend is the like
not calling the start and select button
start and select like they have the
adopting that three line thing that Xbox
did this generation you know they have
this like weird like spiked three lines
like I'm like what do you call that like
when you tell us your high end like hit
hit the button no I vote you used Mary
Keisha's options which is hamburger and
fries yeah because that's the best thing
to do but like why why what's wrong with
starting select well I saw tweet where
it was like what the hell would you say
if you if someone who doesn't play games
is holding this controller what the hell
button would you tell them to press
still say select I still say start and
slice everyone says it so why not just
yeah call it that
press the hamburger bring back rolls
gamespot start select yeah I don't know
any more thoughts on the controller I
mean I think Lucy's pretty much said it
right like I I'll have no opinions on
this until I guess it's in my hand and
I'm playing a game with fake it's like I
mean Carol guy from Futurama it's like I
have no strong feelings
I think justing thing is like it has to
aesthetically align with the PS 5 in
some way so like it kind of gives you
like a little insight into how the
system itself could look so I mean it
could go either way it could be like the
the main color which is white or there's
accent color which was like a Blacky
bluey style thing but so there's
probably like I bet you they have a
reverse for option as well where you can
get a black controller with white trim
but like I think the key part of it is
like so
to run it through run through it's got
that two-tone color design it's got a
different form fact there's a little
more curvy it's got the light bar is no
longer right at the top it's been eaten
beneath it like to the bottom of it
still there that yeah it was only for VR
right yeah yeah so it's got haptic
feedback so that's something that the
pro controller for the Xbox Series X has
not series X the One X so that's
fantastic
the pro controller - yes someone I've
cause well and like I'm I'm it's helping
me play Doom on console because
otherwise I wouldn't be able to it's got
a depth if triggers which is another
thing is also in elite controller which
is good
rechargeable battery by USB see these
serious has is gonna say that's
important I'm sticking my controller up
but it's not focusing but I hate this
mini USB I hate it because uniformly
everyone's changing to that now yes
that's yeah that's hopefully yeah and
then it's got a built-in mic which is
interesting because they say it's good
for short conversations please like I
described it I described it as the Mikey
you used to say hold on let me get my
mic yeah so that's the mic that you used
to say character yeah remember with
xbox360 you could send voice messages to
people oh that was predominantly how I
like message people on Xbox because
typing took forever yeah so it was me I
don't know how old I was but I had a
much higher pitched voice sending all
these voice messages to people I'd like
probably didn't know that well cuz I
just played Call of Duty with them it
was just oh my god I wish there was no
archive of that stuff not I saved a
bunch of mine so I used to share mine
with my younger brother and my younger
brother was a savant at halo it's scary
how good he was at halo and every time
I'd come home from like school or work
or something I'll turn my xbox on and
there would just be a
a list of aggressive messages for me to
listen to about these people just
screaming a kid for being too good at
Halo and it was the same for like Street
fire and stuff like that I wish I had
those cuz people would they would just
lose their minds it was so funny
alright anyway that's the topics we have
this week just for the record I think
for News we're not gonna like you should
know this by now we're gonna try to hit
all the big stories or all the stories
we're just gonna pick a couple big ones
but we're done with news for now and
we're gonna move on to final fantasy 7 2
more mm-hmm you gave final fantasy 7 a
10 out of 10 which is essential on the
GameSpot scale it is the first 10 you've
given and it is white GameSpot's
a 770 I don't 18th something out of that
wait no cuz I think disco is 16 and then
yeah 18 yeah anyways do you want to sum
up your review just for background like
overall what you thought of it what why
this game you feel is essentially as
quickly as possible I'll give you a
sentence that review was I know I've
said this multiple times but like that
was one of the hardest things I've ever
read I love reasons you're at your final
line like I think really like it feels
profound that you say in the end of that
a lot of people a lot of it comments you
notice that - I've been trying not to
read the comments because I'm terrified
of words no they're super very good it's
surprisingly positive at least for you -
I don't know about GameSpot people
always find something to complain about
in games about comments oh yeah I mean
like it's it was a difficult game to
talk about but I can serve I could say
that I I loved it enough to give it and
and like there's something I've been
thinking about what is about it that
made me push it because the obviously I
you all know that I also love Sakura and
I reviewed that last year and I give her
a nine
and I was like looking at Final Fantasy
and I was like why why did I give this a
10 I can still have a 9 what was it
about yet and I think part of it is the
nostalgia and to ignore the nostalgia
would be stupid but I don't think you
can do that it would be I think you'd be
failing at your job if you ignored the
nostalgia part of it and acted like it
didn't have an impact on you so I put a
bit in my review where I said yeah it
works as it no store does what not that
what it does to you but it's important
to know is that like it does more than
that and I think John Luke is a
testament of this and same for a bunch
of other people if you listen to any
other podcast like the kind of funny
guys
Greg Miller was talking about it same
for blessing I believe Andy Cortes
there's a bunch of people who have never
played the Final Fantasy 7 original and
I just like this is unreal and I think
the reason I deserves a 10 is it
executes on exactly what I wanted to be
but but is why I wanted to be wasn't
just a remake it was like taking
something that was beloved and remaking
it in a way that is better than the
original very few things can do that
we've had amazing remakes over the years
Shadow of the Colossus remake is
fantastic there's various other remakes
are good but nothing that took the
original source material and reworked it
into something as good as this people
are listening to this who are like
inclined to complain are gonna complain
about things that are changed in the
story and yeah it does change things in
the story and it sets up things that to
be very different in the future going on
and like the problem I have with that
mentality is like I I see a lot of
people saying how can you give it a 10
when they did X Y & Z to this to this
thing and changed it and my thinking is
like but it doesn't right now I can't I
can't ding it for something that it
hasn't done what the game is is just
outstanding it's phenomenal it's this
beloved story told in a way that feels
modern and more human and more relatable
and more like just heartfelt it's it's a
level of of like nuance and writing that
I just did not expect from I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be hundreds in earnest I
didn't expect it from Square Enix and he
expected from Final Fantasy I know I
shouldn't say that because because
because
Zev exists and Ziv is buzz ever still
like the exception
it was the exception it was the one
final fantasy game where if I'm was here
he'd be going mad but like that is the
strongest real and final fantasy game
that exists but again like the main line
final fantasy games are created by a
different team they don't have the same
writer and the writing quality on those
is subpar for me like it's not good it's
it's archetypes and they create
interesting worlds but there's things
about those games that I just don't ever
hit for me like the dialogue is off
often miss for me but in this game every
part of there is it feels like it lands
and it feels like it was really
carefully thought thought of and
executed on like there's so many funny
moments so many lines of dialogue that
are endearing heartwarming yet as the
odd clunker but it doesn't detract from
the experience
there are moments like where I thought
this does this is a level of poignancy I
never thought I'd get from Final Fantasy
there's lines where like the comedic
timing on is just perfect like there's
this and it's not just is written as a
well good joke it's written well it's
delivered perfectly and then the camera
angle the directing behind it absolutely
nails it there's one line in particular
which I won't spoil which is like a
character is dressed in a way that no
one else expects and he's very much
aware of the fact that everyone else is
like why why why you dressed like that
and the delivery of his line which
responds to to the kind of like the
incoming barrage of questions about the
situation it's just if flawless like I
remember thinking that is that is like
high level comedy standard delivery and
it's coming from final fantasy which I
didn't expect
but like it's an incredibly nuanced
story it deals with you know an
eco-terrorist group and it doesn't shy
away from the fact that some people
don't believe in their cause and for a
lot of the time the things that they're
trying to achieve are hurting the people
around them and although sure in the
future it may pay dividends there's a
small chance that it might improve
things you're constantly being reminded
that this is a small group of people
fighting a behemoth and is there really
worth in sacrificing so much for the
small chance that you might change
something the people around you are
constantly reminding you of that the
characters that are involved in that
story are also reminding of you of that
Tifa for example I mentioned in the
reviewers like she's constantly
second-guessing herself and she's
second-guessing the cause she's and
she's doing it not just because as a
scripted thing she's looking they show
what what she's thinking about they show
a character called Marlene who's the
little girl who works in the bar that
she works at and it's like the main
character of one of the main character
Barrett's door and like you can see that
some of her concerns are because of what
she feels for Marlene and what if she
feels for the people around her and it's
such a nuanced way to think about it and
that kind of stuff is is just it's
considered and it fleshes those
characters out in a way that the
original just wasn't at all and then
there's like stuff like the combat which
I described like as the perfect balance
between action from like the 15 era and
like lightning returns and all those
kind of the lightning series and the
classic 137 where you're just standing
in one spot and issuing commands there's
like a perfect but it's the first time I
described it as in my review that the
action focus doesn't come at the expense
of their strategy it just feels so good
and they kept the materia system and
they made it work well the materia
system is probably my favorite RPG
upgrading system because if four people
don't know like you get this gem which
essentially encapsulates the magical
ability and then you use it and it
levels up and then you can take that gem
and give it to any character and it's
not like that character is not not
proficient in it because the experience
that you've pumped into the gem and that
magic it carries over so you can just
turn your like melee fighter into a
long-range magician if you want to and
it's just works so good it's so freeform
you can come out whenever you hit a
roadblock with a character or a boss or
something like that you can just think
about how can I make this interesting
and make it more kind of fun for me to
mess around with the loadouts and see if
I can figure out another way to come out
that is fun the music is unreal oh it is
on
my god is this I have thought about the
the soundtrack is $80 and I constantly
think about buying it and like occasion
to buy that yeah I always veteran or
Rippey and put on because I it'll be
fine I was I was very very happy that I
found a version of it of the soundtrack
that I've been taken from the demo on
YouTube because when I was writing it I
like to try and get into the mindset of
the game I'm playing and I had that
playing in the background and okay it
made me it makes you emotional he make
me it made me emotional right like I was
able to try and the one thing I
struggled with was properly representing
my feelings about the game but also
making sure that I'm doing justice to
the fans that love Final Fantasy 7 I
wanted to make sure that like my fandom
was obvious to them so so that they
could look at me and my review as
someone they can trust but doing it in a
way that doesn't push it into the
territory where people think that I'm
not considering the things I'm saying
because I'm so blinded by my love of it
and that balance is really difficult to
strike and like I had that music playing
and there were moments where I'd like
just listen to the music to try and find
the words I wanted to say and that that
orchestral soundtrack is so evocative is
so well done the motifs that it carries
through like they're they're so subtle
at times but then they build the
crescendos and whether it's like
sephiroth's theme or Aris theme or just
like a random theme that is playing
while you're wandering like a sewer
district it's just it makes you listen
it's on I don't want to say it's on par
with persona 5 because persona 5 has a
very distinct style and pop and but like
in terms of quality and thoughtfulness
in production I think it's there it's
one of my favorite video game
soundtracks of all time and that is in
keeping with every other aspect of the
game
visually it's absolutely stunning it's
one of the best looking games I've seen
and I don't put a lot of stock into
like how good a game looks and people
have been pointing out all these low-res
textures in there but I honestly people
pointing that out are doing that at the
expense of everything else that looks
amazing
you look as slow as textures and
everything okay but like in the thing
that blows my mind is like they're
looking at other people are looking at
this door which is like low blow poly or
like this flower and in the background
is this unbelievable varsity there's
like this this this massive plate above
them in the sky that is blocking out the
Sun and the moment you look at it it's
just like you get this feeling of
oppression and feeling of like being
unable to escape the misfortunes of
living in the slums or like you look at
a character like Tifa or Barrett and
like you can see like into their eyes
and almost feel that they're alive and
like they the way their hair moves the
way they you know just behave in
movement and that all is just lost and
pushed aside because there's a flower
that's got not enough polygons and I'm
like you're missing the point here it's
just a gamer's yeah I'm like I'm not I'm
not trying to hate on people like people
care about things to different levels
but there's so much beauty in this game
it's overwhelming at times there's
there's points where you're so high up
in this tower and you're looking over
Midgar and it will stop you in your
tracks because it's like you see in the
distance this horizon and there's a
desert Beyond and the light looks like
it's filtered through this this like
sand dunes and it's like covering the
city and you just look out there and
you're like this is unbelievable how
good this looks and it's just it's just
phenomenal to look at and I don't think
it's a as people say like all low res
low poly whatever it's just one of the
most stunning games I've ever seen and I
can't believe it's the kind of game this
is how you'd imagine a game would look
this far into a Playstations lifecycle
it's done did you did you play on
PlayStation 4 PlayStation 4 Pro just out
of curiosity I played on a pro and that
Pro was putting in work like there were
times when I'm glad I had that sound bar
because I had to crank it roll up to
drown and drown up the ps4 as fans but
it will make your ps4 work but that's
just like one part of it that it's the
if the characters they're really really
really well
stick with you and like they I said in
my review but this is this is why people
love these characters like you could you
love them people love them back then but
there was a lot of like filling in the
gaps putting pouring your own ideas and
thoughts into these characters that had
been like created almost as character
shows but like they're very thin when
you look at them now but you I dare
anyone to spend some time with Aerith
and not just be like I love her I love
her so much and like just be around Tifa
and look at her and just be in awe of
how powerful she is what she just like
destroy the world around her with her
punches and kicks she's such a
powerhouse and then she'll come to you
and have this moment of vulnerability
that will just make your heart sink and
it's like having a close friend open up
to you and like Barret you see him he's
like I described him as like a WWE
pay-per-view character because he's just
screaming and and he's always doing
cutting a promo but then you have a
moment when he just picks up his
daughter and says something to her and
it will just melt your heart and like
wedge and Barrett Gretchen
Biggs and Jesse and Jesse as a character
that is just given no time in the
original game and you meet her and she's
she throws herself a cloud she's like
maybe you'll be like you know my leading
man and she's like she is very much
horny on main like everyone everyone is
game but like there's a moment where you
do a quest and you really like the quest
you do a mission I hate the scrubbing of
his missions and quests because it just
sucks the the heart out of it you do you
go on like you do this job with her and
you've realized why she's like that she
has this she had a dream and it an
impact her did her personality in a
specific way and then you'd look at her
completely different from that point and
you're like oh I understand why you
behave like this you know it makes you
think about that case same for like pigs
as well like pigs as a character who
like seems like he's just very carries
my egg like cool calm collected soldier
type and then you there's a line someone
says where they're talking about someone
else in their past and they mention a
name and you're like
oh wait a second you connected to this
connectivist connect to this and you
were here doing this thing and you're
like I did not expect you to have a role
in this thing that's happening in front
of me and like even this there's a small
thing that I use to highlight why it is
essential to try and do everything in
that game there's this mission where you
go to a part of the city and a character
which is a teacher asks you to find a
bunch of our students that are running
around the city on patrol and is you
look at it and I even I remember going
great it's basically a dynamic fetch
quest and you can run around this area
and find these kids and I did it I found
these kids I returned them home some of
them like what Ricky had to find because
his enemies that you fight on the way
and they're in the area and then a few
years a few missions later I had to do a
similar mission which was like the same
mission the kids are off again or you
need to go and find these kids and I was
like what is this and then I found those
kids every single one of those kids was
wearing a wooden version of clouds
Buster Sword on their back because they
he had rescued them he had become their
hero and now they were going around town
just trying to be like loud and that was
like I could have missed that easily but
that little bit of character development
and you could see the impact it has on
cloud he's this cold-hearted character
he only wants money
but then he even he sees these kids who
idealize him and he's like damn I've
gotta pay attention to what's happening
and you can see him like he's thrust
into these relationships that he doesn't
want to start with and he just can't
escape him and it's he's caught on a web
of like humanity and that's the most
interesting part of this game and like I
said like there's a point where you meet
air if you walk through an area with her
and honestly like the music playing
speaking to her like I I couldn't
contain my emotions I was like I just
burst out crying cuz I was like this is
everything I wanted it to be and like
that specific moment speaking to eros it
was like I think it's one of the one of
the greatest mom game moments I've ever
had so I love this game to to bits and
it's important to once again reiterate
that is enhanced by my
nostalgia for the game but I think if
you if you even someone like who has no
nostalgia for it can see the value in
great yeah jean-luc as well it's never
quick to him before and he was telling
me like the same just like how much he
was a greedy enjoy surely the air I mean
I almost like I'm more interested to see
what people think of this game who are
nostalgic because I feel like nostalgia
is tricky right everyone's quick to say
oh this is just fuel by your nostalgia
but if you're a nostalgia for something
and they like mess it up or something
isn't quite right like those are the
people that are gonna notice and those
are the people that is gonna call it out
it's not the people who are like passing
fans like myself like I'm not gonna I'm
gonna play this game I'm not going to
notice that kind of stuff because I'm
not nostalgic but I that that's why like
hearing the fact that you're nostalgic
and it's still it it is more than what
you'd expected and all that stuff makes
me even more excited to play this game
am more interested but I guess just to
kind of like move things along here
jean-luc you're someone who didn't play
the original Final Fantasy 7 right and
you're still really enjoying it - oh
yeah yeah I never like a hundred percent
agree with everything tomorrow said and
I never played the original Final
Fantasy 7 I have no nostalgia for it I
the few Final Fantasies I've tried a
bounced off of 13 I thought was
incredibly dull I 15 I like parts of it
and then got bored of it pretty quickly
this I was kind of I was expecting like
I was excited to try it but I was like
you know I'm not really sure how it's
gonna feel about it and I just kind of
wanted to know you know what this final
fantasy thing is all about because it is
that like one that everybody is so
nostalgic for and it is just it's so
it's so well done the characters are
like eat like in that first I played
that first hour I played like the demo
which is essentially the first chapter
and I remember being like yeah this is
okay I was kind of irritated to bear it
and and I was sort of like I don't know
if this is gonna if these characters are
gonna work for me but like it
they if I if you felt that way the same
way I did I would say like you have to
give it more time because like almost
immediately I feel like those characters
start to like expand and develop more
and then like my initial impressions of
Barrett as like you know tomorrow said
he's just a very loud boisterous person
like melts away when he interacts with
his daughter and even like his
relationship with cloud-like develops
and it it's just really like interesting
just like back and forth between them i
I think the the like way the story
develops it it was so interesting like
because I was the only one in the office
who like hadn't played the original who
is playing it who got it early and I
just assumed that all is the like story
stuff all of these like added layers of
like social commentary were in the
original and they they aren't like
they're kind of there but they're like
people being like oh yeah like that
wasn't in there and like you didn't they
really didn't like dive into like
dealing with the consequences of being
you know part of this like eco-terrorist
group and like the convictions of your
choices and sort of like the social
hierarchy of this like corporation who's
kind of oppressing this system like it's
there but it's apparently it's just not
it was it was kind of more surface level
and I was shocked because it felt so
core to the story it felt like like are
you kidding me like this this is what's
making this story for me and like I was
I was baffled that a lot of that stuff
was just not in the original like it
feels so necessary so quick quick
question for two more soon this is
obviously part one of three parts right
mm-hm
or multiple parts how no how long is
like like if you take this section how
long is this section in the original
game what about three hours okay so okay
that's what's this thing okay so there's
a lot of as I say three hours is
probably an overestimation if anything
it might be like two been been played
who's been playing it for the first time
recently he said it took him about five
ish okay so but he said I mean it's
longer than I remember that but it's a
fraction of the story yeah cuz how long
is dig
overall like the the when you're in
Midgard that's like only is wait did I
get it right yeah yeah yeah
fake final fantasy fan here like how
long is the game overall like once you
get out of there it's pretty long still
is it's like 80 hours the original yeah
yeah the original is like a minimum of
the problem with that game not problem
is the thing that game is like it's
called layers upon layers of buried
stuff so you can go 400 yeah if you
wanted to but like minimum just like 50
goes 5060 hours if you're doing
everything you can in the team path but
like this game is 40 hours based on a
three hours for three to five hour
structure of the original and yeah Pike
and it doesn't feel like they were just
adding in filler like you know it all
feels substantial it all feels yeah well
it all feels impactful it all feels
essential that's why I described it as
in my review like it doesn't it doesn't
make sense that this wasn't here it
doesn't make sense how this story could
have been told without this because it
seems so crucial to the tale yeah and it
just plays so good like like you said I
I've never I didn't like the combat and
15 like it it feels like they took a lot
of lessons from the way fifteen played
and really applied it to this one like I
think that combat like I've if they
finally like figured it out you know
like it feels like squares been like
trying to figure out how to like
modernize Final Fantasy combat for four
years and they've never quite hit it and
this feels like the first one where like
it feels good it is like just bouncing
back and forth between characters and
like queuing up the commands and like
when you figure out that system and you
like have all of your you know
character's abilities set in the materia
and you are like planning and
micromanaging your attacks and firing on
all cylinders like it's so satisfying
because you can the combats actually
like pretty tough like if you're not
doing a good job you can die really
easily but then when you like figure it
out and you nail it
it is like so satisfying yeah there's
not there's no like random in the
originals they'll be like you take it
three steps and you'll be in a random
battle and you're fighting like
constantly this is way more conservative
in the amount of fights you have and
because of that each fight is more in
depth and like more meaningful it's it's
they're trickier they feel closer to
something like you know a mini-boss
every skirmish is a mini-boss and then
there are bosses in between but yeah it
demands a lot of you but once you figure
it out it's it's this kind of
satisfaction that you have in playing a
Fire Emblem a XCOM that kind of
strategic movement of things and the
satisfaction of watching your plans pay
off in the way that you want to them and
even that persona style thing where you
identify a weakness and then you exploit
it and it puts that enemy on their on
their backs and then you further jump in
that kind of like the stagger system is
just like that where you apply a
pressure once you exploit a weakness a
applies pressure to them and then if you
keep doing that they're staggered and it
leaves them completely open this doesn't
have an all-out cinematic attack but it
just means that you can pile on the
damage and it feels so good when you do
that because you feel smart and you feel
like you've you've kind of like figured
out a character I figured out an enemy
yeah in a way that like 15s never did
like I I just remember like 15 feeling a
little like I'm just spamming the button
I'm kind of going through the motions
like it didn't quite click for me that
way know what Jake's going yeah camera's
not Memphis it's fine I'll turn it back
on soon but yeah like it's just like in
15 I just remembered that combat being
like pretty like I'm just kind of going
through the motions and hitting the
buttons and this I felt like I'm
constantly thinking about it and and
even like 15s open-world there are
elements of it I like but I think it was
- it suffered from just like it took
forever to get anywhere and a lot of
times it felt like filler like this
feels I think the restricted nature of
the environments really benefits the
game it feels like every area it feels
handcrafted it feels like like when you
do the side missions it's like these
small little town areas that that just
feel big enough to feel fun to roam
around in but don't feel like too big
where you're just like aimlessly
wandering around in a way that I I feel
like about a lot of open-world games it
it has huge Yakuza energy
you and me were both saying that like
both in the structure but then like
you've mentioned that the humor is like
it it does I don't know if that's what
they did but it feels like they took
some lessons from like the way Yakuza
fuses like it's super serious tone with
it's like jokey like comedic moments and
it feels like they nailed that to me and
that's coming from like a Yakuza fan
first not a final fantasy fan like I
know the original game also had its
goofy moments but something about the
way they deliver it in this one it works
it doesn't feel like irritating in the
way that I've played other JRPGs were
like it's just like oh this character is
trying to be funny but just comes off as
really obnoxious like that doesn't
happen in this game there are parts in
the original where the goofier parts are
actually in by modern standards would be
described as problematic oh sure yeah
those those are in this remake but they
are handled in to know everyone's
everyone's do everyone's you know is
different but I would describe as
progressive I would describe as smart I
would describe it as like very well done
very well done and unexpectedly like
very very respectful I there's a moment
which could have been a in the old game
would have been a lot of think pieces
and we're complaining in this game
I felt uplifted by it if I saw it I was
like I can't believe they said that and
that is exactly what a lot of people
will be wanting to hear is it is it what
happy to hear is it what the guy said
after the unexpected I so I'm go we got
to move on here but that I stuck with me
as well yeah but before before we do
that I do want to mention that next week
you guys are going to do a spoiler cast
which will go up in this podcast feed so
make sure to check that out and actually
before we move on Lucy I was curious if
you are planning on do you have an it
you have experience with Final Fantasy 7
are you planning on playing this like I
kind of want to know your background
because you enjoyed Final Fantasy 15
right I did but I didn't finish it
because of chapter 13 which so yes I
know
finished it even though I know they
patched it I'm a big Kingdom Hearts fan
for my sins but I really enjoyed the
demo for seven hearing you guys talk
about it reading Tam's review listening
to Greg and talking to Greg about it I'm
really pumped to play remake and I was
actually like actually debating whether
or not to stop persona 5 this close to
it but I think persona is one of the
games that I can just do in the
background because I feel like I'll
finish Final Fantasy and if I time it
right that's when there's the new story
stuff in persona will be coming in so
it's like a nice little segue yes things
I couldn't play at the same time no I'm
super excited to play it and I have I
have no fan affiliation really with
Final Fantasy like I love 12 I've been
to a few of the concerts I liked 15
didn't really care for the other ones
that I've tried but I do want to play
you know eight and ten thirteen is when
I'm referring to their better jazz to
play 15 I just apply 7 remake of come 50
cent ring sounds like you and I are in
the same boat except it's not a no I'm
not a Kingdom Hearts fan and I you love
want to make sure everyone knows this is
the game the Kingdom Hearts wishes it
was like okay yeah yeah yeah all right
well I think that's a good enough point
to wrap up this Final Fantasy 7 review
discussion if you want to hear more tune
back in next week like I said in this
podcast feed John Luke is going to be
doing a spoiler cast so make sure you
finish the game obviously but keep it
out for that should be more good
discussion about the game but let's move
on to listener questions Lucy do you
want to take this first Jeremy and on
discord channel um one thing I should
mention sorry if you want to mess if you
want to send us questions do it after
dark podcast at Gamescom or join our
discord all these questions this week
are actually from the discord because I
was trying to dig through my GameSpot
after dark label and it was kind of a
mess because a lot of people are asking
for discord access and whatnot don't
worry I we
to see your questions we'll get them in
but for this week we just want with
discord to make it simple because it's
been a crazy week anyway sorry continue
that's alright this is from Jeremy who
says I was thinking about this the other
day do you guys remember coming across
any memorable gaming myths when you're a
kid things that you may have heard as a
room at school or from friends that you
tried to prove right or wrong I think
the popular one is finding Luigi in
Mario 64 but personally I encountered a
lot with pokemon ruby sapphire for the
Gameboy Advance
one was that you could become a member
of the elite 4 after beating the pokemon
league championship hundred times I
think I gave up after around 15 tries
and another was that if you solved a
puzzle using Braille you could unlock
this a set of pokémon called Reggie my
jaw dropped and I finally solved the
puzzle and discovered them and to this
day I can't believe that turned out to
be true so I guess my question is did
any of you ever have any gaming myths
like this when you were a kid and did
any of them actually turn out to be true
rails
that's wild yeah so the the Reggie
Steele Reggie ice and Reggie are all
based on Braille puzzles which is
interesting I I guess I never thought of
that most of mine come from Pokemon 2
though like the missingno was one that
turned out asleep no but that was like
people tell you about it like it's
stupid yeah and then sure enough I found
it but then in Pokemon Red and Blue
there are a ton of other stuff like like
me oh under the truck I remember that
one that was a big one and like I even
remember hearing how to become a gym
leader or a member of the Elite Four and
all that stuff if you beat him enough
and just all these ridiculous stories
but another big one too is the original
Animal Crossing i remember hearing from
friends in like online seeing so much
stuff being thrown around about what you
could see and do an animal crossing if
you did these very specific things like
one of which had to do with like
tricking mr. Resetti and doing this
thing and then you can like get rid of
them permanently and all this weird
stuff but yeah those are off the top of
my head what I can think of speaking is
a kind of if you call the help services
it's him on the other line but he is
like actually not in the game at all
like even if you call them he won't show
up which is a bummer
wait has anyone seen
I'm sorry Jeff I was gonna say speaking
of animal crossing I sort of appreciate
how we've had this interesting like
video game myth revival with New
Horizons specifically is don't kick toss
yes I was gonna say yeah my my
girlfriend is both obsessed with Animal
Crossing and tick tock and she is so
frustrated at all these filthy filthy
liars on tick tock who claiming you can
do all these things none of these are
true I'm so mad I put one in our animal
Crossing's like yesterday and it was
like okay I'm gonna try this update
didn't work but I looked at all the
comments on it was something to do with
how to get it to spawn a mystery island
every day she did the same one she tried
the same one all the comments were like
oh my god this worked for me and then
all of the duets were people going no
this doesn't work at all this is a
complete lie I hadn't seen the duets yet
so I'd only seen the comments and I felt
like a fool there's a concerted effort
tik-tok to spread misinformation around
Animal Crossing for some reason it's
wild like I got I did that that thing
happened to me where I got pulled into
the algorithm for animal crossing on
tech talk and I can't get out yeah it's
pure lies it's just pure lies and I'm
like Tommy look would be well upset by
this no the worst bit about being in
Animal Crossing tick tock is everyone
using the same sound Oh me me me me me
me me me me and they do these
conversation so it's like me being
insecure
my boyfriend hyping me up and it's like
okay I've seen your exact same meme
times no use for there's something else
I don't care is that or they're like
flexing on like how good their island
looks but it was also like two days into
the game and I'm like you filthy cheater
I know time skip to get that like yeah
so there's one rumor I
remember from Metal Gear Solid so
there's a pretty early in the game you
need to take the elevator - I think it's
floor b1 and there's a ladder on the far
end that takes you into the vent and
then as you're crawling through the vent
you can look down and see meryl
silverburgh there's a major character in
the game and the franchise just doing
cell ups and those there's this rumor
where if you left the if you after
seeing her immediately backed out of the
divan and then climbed back up in and
did that I think it was 30 times all the
way there all the way back you could see
Meryl with her trousers off and you
could see her you could see her bits and
I was like stupid it is true I was gonna
say that sounds like why I did it I was
like this is gonna be stupid I did it
and it was true and I was like how is
this allowed like it's unbelievable but
like dig the graphics were so bad that
it was just no fun I mean got nothing
either definitely missing no that was
the big playground one at the time when
I was a kid but also naked Lara Croft
gcode that would make Croft naked there
was one that made her explode that was
true but naked it up I think was fake
dad that makes someone else explode all
right moving on all right this next one
is from Jacob also from the discard I
just finished a short hike over the
weekend the accomplishment of finishing
games is great so I wanted to ask what
are your favourite under-the-radar short
games everyone always goes to games like
journey but I'm hoping for more games
like Virginia eightydaze or oxen free
thanks assemble with care on Apple
arcade is a great mobile game kind of in
the line of Florence and that it uses
the touchscreen in really interesting
ways you can blast through that in an
hour or maybe two it's really good and
very emotional and know that many people
are talking about it's on Apple arcade
mmm I like pairing me my love which is a
really interesting game about a girl
who's in a war
on country just trying to make a journey
out of it and it the the gameplay
mechanic is she's texting you so you're
just having this text conversation and
getting updates on her journey and it
gets quite harrowing because you guys
captured and forced into refugee camps
it's it's not a fun time game but it's
emotionally impactful and it doesn't
take up a lot of your time there's a
very natural limitation like she'll send
you a text message and some of it is
really difficult like her last text
message maybe like people are coming for
me and then you won't hear from her for
two days and you're like god I hope
she's okay and then she'll send you a
message they are on maybe you know and
it's like it's very short it takes like
maybe a week or two of our actively
speaking to her to kind of get through
it but it's a good game
mine is a small PC game called the fall
it's basically like a short sci-fi story
it kind of reminds me of those like
Golden Age sci-fi stories are written in
like the 30s and 40s it's I don't want
to say much about it you basically play
as like a robot who it's a robot AI in a
in a like a combat suit and your pilot
like kind of crashes on this planet and
is and is like knocked out it's like in
a concussion and so you have to like
take over the suit to try and protect
your pilot and your AI is sort of like
going through this world that is with
all this like dysfunctional robots and
and it gets really dark and it has some
like really I think it's just like such
a well-told short story it only takes
like a couple hours there is apparently
a second there was a second part that I
think came out last year I didn't play
it I heard it was not as good but but
again I am play it for myself but even
then I think like just that first part
like stands on its own and I highly
recommend it it's just a really really
good short sci-fi story yeah I don't
know if this one's super under the radar
but the first thing that came to mind
from those ABS ooh
probably cuz you mentioned journey in
there and I know there are some similar
devs working on the two but like I think
Abzu is the only game I can think of
that has like swimming mechanics that
are fun and it's pretty short you can
finish it and it's beautiful the music's
really good
I think it took me about two or
two-and-a-half hours or so but it is a
very like meditative game that I highly
recommend like plugging in headphones it
just I don't know especially during
these times are in right now just
carving out a couple hours and just
playing it because it will definitely
relax me and there is some some the
story is like it's not super complex I
would say but but I really like the
themes of it and like where where it
goes throughout the two-hour run time is
really interesting
alright I don't know anything else
anyone wants to add okay we've got one
more question here tomorrow do you want
to read this one yeah this one is from a
serious business all the talk about
animal crossing has made me think about
games that have come out either the
perfect or the worst possible time what
games have been a huge hit or miss for
you purely because of when they released
I absolutely love the persona series but
I have not completed us on a fire
because they came out at a time when I
was severely depressed the mood and tone
of that game was too much even the dark
red and black design felt like an
aggressive attack on my mood on the flip
side of that the Mass Effect series was
released during a period when I was
grappling with my sexuality and felt
very alone being able to roleplay as
friendship and have a relationship with
Lee ro was whilst being surrounded by an
incredibly supportive an open-minded
crew except Ashley but you actually it
was exactly what I needed
PS thanks again for all the content you
folks are continuing to provide I can
tell you how much is helping to keep me
sane my cohan's review of persona 5 was
so incredible that it makes me want to
conquer my fears and go back to finish
what I started thank you
damn yeah I think for me Mass Effect was
one of the big ones yeah I yeah I was
struggling with depression back in when
it came out and I remember sitting down
in just in a dark room and starting that
game the first one and it's being fully
absorbed by it and like for a little
while just consumed in my life and
I remember it fondly and I think I think
I would be a different person if I
didn't have that game at that time yeah
I would say I mean Mass Effect for me
too but I think thinking that really
reminds me of that as the original
retention I remember getting it launched
and that was at the end of I think my
first year of university yeah would have
been and I was super unhappy at uni I
hated it and I just like sank all this
time into red dead and I like you said
with Mass Effect became completely
consumed by it and but that's how I
started to talk to more people about
games and I got in my first like
multiplayer Posse with people that I
only sort of knew and then you know
became better friends from there and
yeah right dad yeehaw I think mine was a
the original persona for that came out
like when I think I was like literally
the same age as the characters in that
game when it came out like in high
school so just like that like their
their struggles in that game like really
hit me on another level as much as like
I hate characters like Yosuke like when
did some of the stuff that Yosuke deals
with in that game like with his boss
like really resonated with me and
characters like Chie and like I think
just sort of like the idea of like
overcoming your yourself and your own
fears and anxieties and like having a
group of friends like that just really
connected with me at the time when I
came out so yeah that game really means
a lot to me I mean I would say Last of
Us for me the first one because that
came out at a time where I was like
pretty I was in school but I like had no
idea what I wanted to do like I didn't I
had very little direction I had just
dropped out of a different college that
I was in that I wasn't I like was
spending a lot of money and I wasn't
happy and I had no idea what I wanted to
do and I started playing last of us and
I was so entranced I don't know playing
through multiple times I still play
through it every single year I've done
grounded mode multiple times like that
game means a lot but I think
ultimately like the biggest thing I
guess I owe to that game or like the the
biggest thing that always reminds of is
that that was the game that I played and
I was like man I want to like cover this
game somehow even though I'm not paid
like I like that's not something I ever
thought I wanted to do until I played
Last of Us and and then my mind was
going crazy with like this is what this
means like I I just
there was like yeah I don't know like I
guess that was the start of what became
a career in this industry just because
that really got me to think about games
in a very different way so yeah I would
say that came out at the perfect time
just because it gave me direction and I
didn't have direction in a very strange
way which is another big reason why I'm
very bummed that we're gonna have to
wait much longer for the last missed
part two before we misschien before we
move on I think it's worth trying to go
back to personify especially with Roy
out there because it I hope that you're
in a bed we all hope that you're in a
better place now it sounds like you may
be but that game for as difficult as the
stalling is is about rebelling against
the things that hold you back
and the people that hold you down and
it's about empowerment so those reds and
blacks that might be attacking you back
then they can very quickly become
something that you will see and identify
with the feeling of empowerment and the
feeling of being able to take life and
destiny into your own hands and and
fight back against it and feel good
about the power you will and take action
so I mean your mileage may vary and your
sensitivities at different hours but
that is what that game is about and we
gave it a 10 but for a reason because we
think it executes on that so well and
we're all fans of that game and it has
it has helped us and touched us in
different ways so we would buy I would
recommend it I'm sure the others would
agree as well I don't even like anime
and I'd recommend it anyway that's when
episode 36 of GameSpot after dark thank
you so much for tuning in sticking with
us during these these confusing times
before we get into plugs and whatnot the
the big plug that I want to mention is
the game spot this cord if you want in
on the games about this cord
DME send us an email at after dark
podcast at GameSpot comm and we will get
you in there one thing that I haven't
mentioned before that I should mention
is that these invites expire after 24
hours so if you're if you don't check
your email super often I'd recommend
just DMing me or jean-luc on Twitter and
we'll make sure to get you in I mean if
not we can just keep sending you invites
until you make it in but that is one
thing to consider when you're doing
please make your first message hello
Gordon so we know that yes hello hello
Gordon or have you seen my passport so
just kind of good general and drop those
in there and then we'll know that that's
like when youtubers are always like if
you've made it to the end of this video
comment like yeah like I don't know like
money making tips or some random
discount code use discount code hello
[Laughter]
and huge thank you to everybody that's
already joined and in there and just
like having conversations like you guys
have been honestly like it makes my day
feel better I think yeah it can be a
little tough engaging with audience and
in our job especially because like
anybody on the internet can just click
on our videos or go to our website and
leave a comment and that leads to a lot
you have to you have to sift to find the
good stuff and like this discord is just
like this filtered like pure positivity
so huge shout out to everybody who's
joined so far because it it makes me
feel a lot better when I when I check in
and you guys are just talking about your
favorite games or letting us know that
you liked a video or something we worked
on that that always choose me up yeah
definitely and shout out to John Luke
because John Luke did a lot of the heavy
lifting for that and very happy it's
finally there Lucy what do you want to
plug uh well I'm just about to film this
episode of good news gaming so let me
plug that they'll be going up on Friday
as well please look up did a video all
about it is an incredible story about
the original Resident Evil
jool shock version soundtrack which is
the story is like falling down a
Wikipedia hole the guy who it's a
famously terrible soundtrack and the guy
who composed it was death all was he and
unbelievably that's not even the
weirdest twist in that's please go watch
it it's fake genius I have been obsessed
with that song for years and I had no
idea that Kurt was making a video on it
so like waking up and seeing that like
made my day I was like I have to watch
this like oh my god yes yes because oh
that is like one of my favorite weird
pieces of video game trivia so bizarre
you know it's a great video and yeah
that's it and I'm on Twitter at least
Jim's game tomorrow how are you get your
review up from yeah you can check out my
Final Fantasy 7 remake review on
GameSpot calm and please go to youtube
as well and check out the video review
which John Luke did a magnificent job on
I wish there a bunch of times in our
collaborative qae service frame and it's
just is phenomenal it's just he hit all
the beats that I would want a video
review he made my words sound good which
is amazing
yeah and that's pretty much it I'm at 2
more hate went where John Luke I was
also gonna actually pimp that video it's
it's a weird one like I like video
reviews are always a weird one for me
because I'm just taking someone else's
review and I'm like you know making a
video out of it so it feels weird to
call like it's my video but for whatever
reason but like I felt I mean not to say
that I don't put any effort into any
reviews but I felt very compelled to
like make this as good as possible and
like there was a point where it was
basically done and like I should have
stopped like it was like 6 o'clock and I
was like no I'm gonna I need to pull out
the PlayStation 1 over there and capture
so that I can just make this intro
exactly how I want it like I just fell
like temor your your review was like so
good that I was like I have to I have to
do this justice so I saw that the hop
skip and jump for H was just absolutely
for
I was like he's clearly putting yeah so
so I feel very proud of that one I think
that's one of my best video reviews I've
done so I would also recommend you go
watch it and you can find me at a John
excite key on Twitter cool and you can
find me at Jacob deck on Twitter and I
bet I just probably more Animal Crossing
guides that I've worked on coming up so
if you need more animal crossing guys or
here for you anyway if you were the
person feeding all the fake tick-tock oh
god that would be a story let's end this
podcast now to go down this rabbit hole
by day he makes animal cooking tips
guides by night he lies to the kids I'm
ticked I ain't dead that's how I got to
get content so you can make videos like
myth-busting like yes thinking ahead
anyway we'll see y'all back soon
[Music]